it feels like just yesterday Elden ring
was hitting store shelves and taking
over the world but in reality that was
over a year ago now Bandai Namco is
celebrating the first anniversary of the
game with an infographic revealing some
of the first year's most impressive
statistics Elden ring players have died
more than 9 billion times with 69 of
those deaths coming from enemies or NPCs
15 percent of the deaths were due to
status effects 14 from falling and only
two percent of player deaths were caused
by other players players have also
attempted nearly 6 billion boss fights
in the first year with Millennia
receiving the most attempts at
329 million Margaret ranks second with
281 million followed by Lim grave tree
Sentinel at
277 million radagon at 148 million and
radon at 139 million those are some
gigantic numbers and as someone that
normally Skips from soft games it is an
honor to have all of my deaths be a part
of that 9 billion now if only I had the
privilege of summoning let me solo her
the legendary Elden ring player known
for helping others defeat Millennia I'm
sure he's on to bigger and better things
now like challenging himself with the
mod that replaces all enemies with the
famed blade of Michelob this Millennium
mod is created through the item and
enemy randomizer mod and players can
choose specific settings like scaling
enemy health and damage it also seems
like Millennia in the mod is very aggro
as pointed out by let me solo her and
will hunt players down until they reach
a site of Grace lemi solohire ended the
first stream by taking down Magna War
Millennia and draconic Millennia and is
planning on continuing in the near
future past players have successfully
cleared a mod where everything is
Millennial before with YouTuber bushy
streaming a successful completion and he
listed his goals as no leveling Vigor
getting the jar Helm his signature
accessory and beating the game but
that's enough Elden ring talk for right
now let's talk about another game with
swords and Magic Final Fantasy 16.
according to a famatsu interview with
the game's director and producer Final
Fantasy 16 will take around 70 to 80
hours to 100 percent director Hiroshi
takai told the site quote you'll see the
entirety of Clive's way of life and the
game will probably take about 35 hours
to clear if you include side content it
could be double that amount while
there's plenty to do if you want to earn
the 100 completion it's where Annex
wanted to ensure that busy players could
reach the end of the game in a
reasonable amount of time producer nyoki
Yoshida said quote when the game
development was just starting out I had
the idea in mind that Gamers these days
are really busy with other things so I
wanted them to at least aim to complete
the story I thought making the game
something you can complete in about 20
hours would make sense but more and more
just got packed in Yoshida went on to
explain that there is also an quote
insanely difficult New Game Plus Mode
called Final Fantasy mode that will
allow players to carry over all stats
and cool probably add even more gameplay
hours are you ready to lose all your
free time to Final Fantasy 16 let me
know in the comments below and I'll see
you tomorrow
foreign